[Music]
[Music]
knock it off you can't do that
guys guys guys listen rafi
just got out of treatment remember
we don't want to trigger him with tennis
lapis
hey what up what's going on here
why are we all acting at the funeral
here
no nothing uh rafi you just caught us in
the lull in the conversation man we're
[Applause]
i was happy stay for a second cause i
mean that was a good game huh good game
hey good game
good game man
good game
okay
there's an elephant in the room
you know i want to talk about it
see i had a problem
it was bad and my lowest point
i would sneak into a horse's table
when you find yourself at 1am in the
morning with your hand in the air
and horse's ass in front of your face
that's when you know
it's pain but i'm okay now
i'm all better guys honestly just treat
me like i'm normal
okay okay raffi let's have some fun okay
[Music]
you can pick up your glove
[Music]
come on
hey what i told you huh it's just normal
guys come on
is he i'm fine i'm all better now you
guys can do the normal stuff
be yourself bend things over pick things
up
you know do your stretches touch your
toes
your stupid
excuse perform hola amigos
my name is ruben i just came over from
the
the braves farm team i'm from the
dominican republic
hello we're off
i'm really excited to be working and
playing with you all go rhinos
all right all right
yeah really put your locker
right next to my locker huh i i guess so
yeah you got this baby you're not
spending a lot of time down there you
know hey i have a lot of stuff
yeah a lot i see that you can do this
oh my god you okay there buddy
not looking too good
i am feeling a bit flushed you know i
got a good feeling about you
maybe we could be good friends maybe
even the best of friends
maybe another time another place
but not here not now
well either way we're teammates and so
anything i can do for you
ask away got it okay go rhinos okay
[Music]
it was just too hard to receive
okay are you okay
okay hey guys
you know maybe after a game victory
we can all go dancing right
now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you